cinquante et une place sièges
inclinables prise usb et climatisation
tout le confort d'un autocar classique à
un détail près si vous avez l'habitude
des voyages en car vous aurez remarqué
que celui ci est particulièrement
silencieux 100% électrique
ce modèle du constructeur be wild y ait
zéro émission de co2 et 0 knox sources
de pollution un véhicule écologique avec
une conduite souple
si je devais refaire un city tour je le
ferais probablement avec celui ci on
ressent beaucoup moins la fatigue
le fait qu'ils soient automatiques qui a
déjà le fait qu'il soit souple
silencieux
tout ce qui est pollution sonore déjà
pour le conducteur c'est très important
parce que c'est source de fatigue
cet autocar a rejoint l'écurie de la
société be green loueur de véhicules de
transport de voyageurs
grâce à son autonomie de 200 km il sera
utilisé pour des excursions ou des
découvertes de sites touristiques
il s'agit du premier de ce type en
europe be green se veut un modèle de
transition énergétique
on se doit de la mettent en oeuvre
puisque ces produits existent
aujourd'hui
donc on doit faire partie des exemples
en matière de transport collectif propre
à partir du moment où les constructeurs
nous présente ces nouveaux véhicules et
notamment celui-ci qui est vraiment dans
la lignée le véhicule du futur qui en
annonce d'autres puisque là on est dans
l'antichambre avec l'électrique
l'antichambre de transport à hydrogène
qui existe déjà
fondée en 2010 be green propose
aujourd'hui 33 véhicules de transport en
commun il est